I feel my name's Wayne I'm a electronic
engineer coming from China big fan to
your show by the way and my question is
mmm hypothetically instead of
politicians afterward were only wronged
by engineers and fungus will it be a
better place you're beaming thanks way
thank you so much for calling in and
thanks for being a fan of the show
you've asked a great question and I
continue categorically the world would
not be a better place run by engineers I
say this all the time
I spend time with rocket scientists a
lot of time with them from time to time
I spend time with Nobel laureates you do
not want these people teaching
kindergarten
by way of example they're just not
qualified when you find somebody who's
interested in making deals in
compromising in empathizing with people
in other words feeling with their
feeling and then trying to establish
laws and traditions that benefit
everyone if when you find somebody who
wants that job that to me is amazing and
we need those people those people would
be politicians with that said what we
want are politicians who are
scientifically literate who are
technically informed now I you're in
China and you have what in the in the US
people often refer to as a technocracy
you have a system of government that is
run largely by engineers or scientists
in what in the US we would call top-down
fashion people at the in power make
decisions for everyone and the system is
workable I mean my goodness China is
this extraordinary economy and and so on
but the experiment in the United States
and the other Western democracies is to
have representatives that work the
system top-down but are elected by
everybody and the idea is that this
would be more fair this would be
consistent with how everybody feels what
we want is people making decisions on
behalf of all of us that are in the best
interest of all of us and the best
interest of everybody has to do with
science and technology we cannot have
sewer systems and the internet and this
communication that you send in here
you couldn't have big think without the
technology of electronics which is
enabled by mining extraordinary metals
and geologists and physicists and
chemists and everybody is fed to
agriculture which is another important
biological aspect of biological science
we need science for everything but what
we want is our politicians to understand
that and appreciate it and celebrate it
and so move science forward there's a
great question but I will tell you in my
opinion having a bunch of engineer and
I'm an engineer don't get me wrong man
having a bunch of engineers run things
it's probably not what you want because
the systems are created engineering
systems are generally created from the
top down and there's just a good chance
you'll miss things you'll make mistakes
and they're harder to correct once
they're in place what you want as
happens in evolution in nature as you
want to the extent possible decisions to
be made from the bottom up and the
expression we often hear in the u.s. is
organically from the bottom up good luck
to both of our governments we all have
to address climate change and I'm glad
that we were able to that our
governments were able to assign a
climate change agreement last year and
I'm very much hoping we can stick to it
because we are going to need everybody
working together to address climate
change and we are especially going to
need scientists and engineers to create
or enable technical solutions to
specific things renewable reliable
electricity for everyone
clean water for everyone and access to
global information the Internet for
everyone thank you way thanks for
calling in
[Music]